is Hunter dodging the court by turning
the White House into a personal Fort
according to the New York Post an actual
paper cat Hunter Biden may be living at
the White House with his second wife and
their three-year-old son in a desperate
attempt to avoid being served legal
papers by his baby mama
it must get hectic with all the crying
and diaper changing
and the baby's a handful too
ah it's because he's old right
there have been several sightings in DC
in the past six months lending or
leading lending Credence to the theory
that he's living with Pops to hide from
process servers and his ongoing child
support fight with the former stripper
and the White House is a great place to
hide it's the last place we saw Chris
Wallace
but the White House they can finally
sterilize his room at the motel 6.
meanwhile house oversight committee
chair or hook
James Comer says at least a dozen Biden
family members will be exposed for
having received money from foreign
entities but hey it's not like the
buy-ins aren't used to being exposed
what
you get to do it never mind but but was
but was this the Biden family influence
peddling scheme
this was the Biden family uh influence
peddling scheme and you know when people
say well they were involved in Ventures
around the world I haven't found any
legitimate business dealings on the
bidening
so despite all that the big guys should
announce anyway his re-election campaign
tomorrow in a pre-recorded video he'll
be holding up a current issue of USA
Today so you know it's not from years
ago
when he still had brain and digestive
functions
become an issue even among those who
support him like a pair of Orthopedic
socks as the New York Times points out
many Democrats particularly younger ones
are worried that he will simply be too
old to be effective in a second term and
by younger voters they mean this
anyway
we were able to obtain an early copy of
Biden's video announcement
my fellow Americans the choice has never
been clear on one side extreme Mega
Republicans racism Charlottesville
January 6. I promise however to wear a
Ray-Ban aviator sunglasses eat ice cream
and occasionally show Passion by yelling
phrases like come on man and give me a
break thank you and God bless the United
States of America come on man give me a
break not a joke
Martha you know we're pinning this on
the New York Post but is that amazing if
he's living at the White House with his
family so he doesn't get yes I mean I
don't know I I mean it's almost two on
the nose a story to be true but I'm
gonna say I believe it and not only that
that same New York Post story says that
Naomi and her husband are also living
there and you see all of these people
coming and going for marine one on a
regular basis There are 16 bedrooms so
there's plenty of room if anybody else
wants to move in I think they have 35
bathrooms and 16 bedrooms
I don't get is you know can you
how can you really they say you might be
avoiding uh getting served papers from
London Roberts by hiding behind the
Secret Service I'm thinking like what
kind of law enforcement official is
going to have you know people come to
serve papers no you can't get in here
yeah it's very strange to me but I also
thought it was interesting what I noted
in that article that London Robert
efforts that this little girl that they
have who's four years old her name is
Navy yes which is interesting because he
got kicked out of the Navy for doing
drugs so maybe she named their child
that to just kind of yeah take it to him
yeah
God there's a joke about well I won't
say it yeah talking about the Merchant
Marine I don't know Nick you know where
my brain's going but uh um one of those
bathrooms in the White House yes have
you been to the White House yes okay we
have people who haven't been to the
White House it's not an attractive place
no the inside is very it's like it's
like somebody let it go to rot 30 years
ago right you know what it is it's like
I slammed without the attitude it's like
the half's Playboy Mansion yeah without
the STDs yeah well not anymore I don't
know about that yeah not anymore yeah so
why would you want to move there unless
you had to well I got to tell you right
now if my father was President I would
be living in the White House you know
and I would invite all of my friends all
the time you would live above the garage
like fonsi absolutely you'd be getting
out I don't even know if there is a
garage in the uh is there a garage
that's a great question I think that's
the one we should be should have been
talking about rather than the check
marks no here's the thing I bet there's
no garage I bet there's no ice maker
yeah right all the things that we take
for granted as modern people are not in
the white house right but Joe Biden is
okay with that because if he has his ice
cream delivered you know uh in a horse
and carriage every day if you don't have
a garage you don't have a second freezer
or a second fridge where you keep the
tall bottles of Pepsi
this is this is a guy who grew up in the
California of the American dream that
was the American dream right the second
refrigerator you had the second
refrigerator you had the you had the
1968 Camaro right blue convertible you
had the freezer in the freezer you had
the tall Pepsis up in the front some
beer in the back and if you had the
second fridge was a sign of status that
was the blue check mark of your cam if
your ranch style home in Menlo Park
packed well that should have been your
monologue
it should have been
so Kat what do you make of this story do
you believe it yeah maybe but I I
wouldn't want to live in the White House
myself why not because there's like P
there's like people who visit it yeah
that's true tours yeah like not anymore
I think it's been pretty much close to
him you can though I I don't I wouldn't
like to be like looking out my window
and then see someone looking back at me
I think it's separated I I've done I
think they keep the the Riff Raff out
and I apologize for that cat I'm not
going to do it again
yeah it does happen yeah I always feel
like no one can see in my windows but I
know that's not true
um I also just feel like you were really
insensitive just now to my fan base yes
of old men yes I was I want to say guys
it's not age it's Joe plenty of 80 year
old men you guys still got it okay it's
just Joe Biden yeah literally I know a
lot of 80 year olds well I mean that's
not true
[Applause]
80 year old
who plead a sentence and more absolutely
not just an age thing it's just that for
any age
he's not with it he's not with it and
it's not even fair to him to make him
run for president yeah I think it's I
think it's unfair I think you're right
when we often make fun of Joe Biden's
age because there are a lot of people
that are in that group but I always say
Rob 80 is the new 50. it really is I
mean think of everything that you have
at your fingertips you have a relief
Factor you have balance of nature you
have relaxium an 80 year old they don't
look a day over like 79. I mean how old
you're almost you're 83 Rob
I'll be 83 in May yeah I look pretty
good yeah uh the difference how is the
relief Factor uh it's not working uh
there's no there's no Factor yeah put
that out um uh there are two kinds of 80
year olds the kind that say I have to go
to the bathroom the kind that say I just
went to the bathroom
um
two kinds
um uh but I I uh I'm actually more
interested in the in the the The
Syndicate that's what I found
interesting about the the New York Post
article I mean yeah I mean look it's so
hundred bides living in the White House
well we know about Hunter Biden is he
rarely leaves the one bedroom like he's
there for like 27 36 hours so no one's
really going to see him you may smell
him but not gonna see him right
um The Syndicate is amazing it's like
everyone said you see those shows in the
like the 80s the the mob like uh yeah
it's like what the shows the mob like
the Expo exposes they have like pictures
of everybody and like now this is like
Sammy uh red sauce uh Biden and over
here is three cheeses Biden and they're
from and that's exactly what it looks
like it looks like a whole Syndicate of
people kind of with they're getting a
little sugar a little taste because the
big man who's kind of losing it there's
going to be a gang war uh I mean I'm
here for it I think it'd be kind of a
cool movie yeah they did it I think it
was called Remember point blank with Lee
Marvin yeah because he works his way up
The Syndicate yeah yeah that's a great
movie and when the Mel Gibson remake was
great too yeah with uh payback yeah
payback great his best movie yeah his
best movie anyway we'll talk about that
afterwards drinks my place hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else